foreign
[Music]
internet we are on a slight tape delay
here with some Bizarro internet issues
so the show is a little late today but
I'm still Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report and it's time for another Friday
Round Table Extravaganza joining me
today is a senior fellow at the
Claremont Institute Dave verboy
political commentator John cardillo and
a New York Post and Fox News columnist
Carol Marco it's all proud Floridians
Dave John Carroll welcome back to the
Reuben report hey Dave hey hey
so uh guys uh we we're all together
earlier this week at the uh the infamous
uh Florida gubernatorial debate where
Ron DeSantis who as I always say cards
on the table we like the guy uh was up
against this Charlie Crist character
who's not really a he doesn't strike me
as a real person he's just a uh he's
just a suit with kind of nothing in it
uh and it was I would say indicative of
what happened in all of the debates over
this week there was obviously the
Michigan debate uh there was the
Pennsylvania debate there were a couple
other debates and and none of them the
New York debate and none of them really
went well for the Democrats so that's
what we're going to talk about today and
uh and then I'm gonna have you guys make
some predictions at the end because
there's nothing that people in our jobs
like more than given predictions uh real
quick though let me talk to you guys
about real estate agents I trust you
guys know that buying or selling a home
is already one of the most stressful
things you can do and it can be 10 times
worse if you're not working with the
right agent usually our homes are
biggest investment which is a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously which is why I
recommend real estate agents I trust
they work with only the best agents in
every Market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their Network and here's a
big one they only work with full-time
Pros no part-time or inexperienced
agents their team makes the introduction
and then follows you through the buying
or selling process to make sure that
you're satisfied the agents they work
with have long track records and they're
the best sellers in their field and even
under these intense Biden related
economic conditions with high interest
rates and high inflation real estate
agents I trust has provided their
customers with agents who've overcome
these challenges in the past they're
part of this audience they share your
values and they're almost anywhere you
want to go just go on over to real
estate agentsitrust.com give them some
basic info they'll contact you to make
an introduction to an agent in your town
you move to Florida and you live happily
ever after and speaking of Florida let's
back up for a moment we'll reverse this
to Monday which was the big
gubernatorial debate and there was a
stark difference between the candidates
here's Governor DeSantis on some of the
woke stuff in schools and what's going
on with all this gender nonsense across
the country and here in Florida
lawmakers are divided on the issue of
gender transitions for minors the
Florida Department of Health has held
firm that there are risks associated
with certain puberty blocking and
hormone therapies for children despite
pushback from the federal government and
other states where do you stand on
minors undergoing so-called gender
affirming medical procedures and
therapies Governor well so-called is
important because when they say gender
affirming care they mean giving puberty
blockers to teenage girls and teenage
boys they mean doing double mastectomies
on young girls they mean chemically
castrating young boys that is wrong we
are not going to allow that to happen
and in the State of Florida a lot of
kids go through a lot of different
things a lot of the dysphoria resolves
Itself by the time they become adults
and we have a number of people that have
spoken out in favor of what we're doing
to say you should not mutilate minors
and they went through this when they
were minors now they're adults and they
regret it and other countries in Europe
that went down this road have now
backtracked and so we're doing the right
thing it's inappropriate to be doing
basically what's genital mutilation
okay so I'm actually not even going to
show any clips of Charlie Chris because
I don't think he's relevant obviously
the uh election is going to be a big
Republican win here and nothing he says
he doesn't even believe what he says so
I don't think there's any point in
giving him air time but Carol I want to
start with you on this one yeah because
every time that either publicly or
privately we talk about this trans thing
you always say you always say I'm a
squish when it comes to these issues
right but but DeSantis pretty much
nailed it there right like basically
said hey kids are kids and yeah we
should let them be kids full agreement
with Governor DeSantis every word that
he said there what I always say that I'm
a squish about is that I don't care what
adults do and so you know look trans
people have been around for a long time
you know it's not a new thing why is it
so hot a topic in our world now is
because they came for the kids they
started indoctrinating the kids into
this wacky gender ideology if a child
was like I feel like a girl they're like
a girl that's it and you know I I say
this a lot but my son thought he was
Batman for a good year and I'm not
joking about this he like would cry when
people would not refer to him as Batman
and like yeah we kind of Let It Go on
but like if you started like you know
actually thinking he was Batman into
adulthood we would have taken steps to
stop that
um so I think that a lot of this kind of
conversation you know the separation
between kids and adults and what kids do
and what adults do is important to me
here and I wouldn't care about the trans
issue at all if it wasn't directly
affecting my small children in their
schools and I just want to say one last
thing about this is that you didn't play
the Christ answer but he did not answer
that question at all he went into a
whole thing about abortion I was looking
forward to hearing how he was gonna kind
of massage it because look nobody wants
gender ideology pushed to their children
in schools and the fact that he couldn't
give any answer whatsoever about it was
really telling yeah well that's sort of
why I'm not playing clips of him because
I don't think he believes anything he's
saying I think he's just like a
fabrication of something which as you
guys know since we were all at the
debate the the DeSantis folks you know
it was basically half and half the
audience the DeSantis people were
individual people by the way everyone
kind of dressed right and it seemed like
they were out for the evening the the
crisp people were all bussed in we think
they were from a teachers union they all
had the same shirts on they they didn't
seem like they were representing
themselves they were just representing
these ideas the trans stuff and the
eight-month abortions and the rest of it
uh Dave I'll go to you next because
you're a little more hardcore on this
than Carol I think yeah I mean I I think
what what Carol said was all fine and
good the problem is is is that the whole
plan was to come after the kids that
there's no there's no magical spot that
we can identify on the let's say the the
sexual rights Continuum where we say
okay this is perfect we're going to stay
here here forever that's a serious
problem that we have I mean it's part of
uh you know I mean it's it's part of
human nature
um never mind
um you know sort of the uh the the plan
of the left to use this stuff to uh to
to
um you know to kind of undermine the
West undermine capitalism undermine
Freedom Etc
so I mean it was always coming for the
kids uh no matter what you know I mean
as as Carol said yes there have always
been people with let's say ambiguous
gender uh conceptions or and unique
gender conceptions
um that that's that's that's fine as
long as they are on the margins and
frankly they always used to understand
themselves as being on the margins
um it was a recent Revolution where they
said no actually
um I am what I say I am and biological
reality be damned and if you say
anything not only are you a bad person
but it's you know they're trying to make
it illegal so so this was where um you
know I mean it's a very difficult thing
to figure out where exactly on the map
to plot where the the the the left turn
went that was that would have been
completely unavoidable
John I suspect you're pretty happy with
the way DeSantis handles all this stuff
it's just clean and clear and he takes
you're a big fan of taking the fight to
them not just waiting on all this stuff
yeah look you know I'm very public about
weaponization I think what we on the
right do very poorly is weaponize our
institutions I think this group we're
pretty effective at weaponizing our
voices and our medium reach but more
people should follow the lead but you
know look the Santa's handled that
perfectly he said in Florida we're going
to let kids be kids we're not going to
let far left radical social activist
parents butcher mutilate their children
now Charlie Chris couldn't answer that
question because Charlie Christ is
whatever it takes for Charlie Crest to
have attention at the moment Republican
independent Democrat once he gets
crushed on Election Day I'm at like 53
54 he's going to show up somewhere in
drag a few months later
Charlene prist you know and then his
like third or fourth sham marriage goes
away but Chris is just an absolutely
horrible horrible disingenuous guy
running for the trial bar right the
Santa's made a good point at the debate
that you know these these insurance
companies are are paying a claimant post
hurricane 28 30 000 but the insurance
companies are making four hundred
thousand dollars the lawyers rather
lawyers making 400 Grand yes that's
because of the trial bar Charlie crist's
Democrats are the sugar daddies of The
Trial Bar Charlie Chris owned sugar
daddy John Morgan Morgan and Morgan for
the people these people fundamentally
hate Liberties this is a cash machine
for them Charlie Christ is running to
see the State of Florida as an ATM for
him like he did before so he can go back
in a private practice and make millions
after this failed governorship uh this
failed Run for the governorship if he
wins God help us he won't but this is
all about money for Charlie Chris
Charlie Chris is all about Charlie Crest
I thought Rhonda sanus was substantive
he's got a track record of success he
did no harm at the debate there was no
need for a gotcha moment or a kill shot
and I think we're going to be really
pleasantly surprised on Election night
yeah and it's interesting because we all
I think have the same reaction after
which was slight disgust of the debate
it wasn't that
um it wasn't somehow that Chris won or
it was even close it was just that
because he will say anything and doesn't
believe in anything there was an
asymmetry of it compared to a guy who's
actually telling you what he believes
and what he's doing and that was just a
little bit bizarre I want to show you
guys one other clip because uh DeSantis
went hard when it came to defending
keeping Florida free and I would also
say this you mentioned Liz that people
are flocking to Florida that would not
have happened if Charlie Chris had his
way he wrote me a letter in July of 2020
saying you need to shut down the State
of Florida he said you need to force
people to shelter in their own homes
that would have destroyed the State of
Florida that would have caused that
would have caused our tourism industry
to go into the toilet it would have
locked out millions of kids from school
I rejected Charlie Chris lockdown on
letter I kept this state open and I kept
the state free
and we now have the biggest budget
surplus in the history of Florida we
have a 2.5 percent unemployment second
lowest on record and we just did the
biggest tax cut in Florida Governor
that's time
Dave are you amazed that you know we
were told before the thing started you
know both sides Be quiet which the
DeSantis side did okay the Chris side
did not so then The Descent decided to
start you know started getting involved
too but are you amazed that there were
people who were actually cheering for
more lockdowns I mean people even here
in Florida seem to want more of the
nonsense it's uh look it's crazy I I I
am not sympathetic to Charlie Crist in
any way
that said he did have an impossible task
ahead of him because I mean he opened up
the debate blasting DeSantis and saying
you're the only one governor in the
history of Florida who's locked schools
down well this is a real disconnect with
his audience and his supporters
especially the crazy people from the
teachers unions in his in his um in the
audience in the crowd because all of
these people loved the lockdowns you
know they they they loved it so he he
really kind of had an impossible task
ahead of him because
um you've got all these contradictory
um all these contradictory ideas you
know they they want to attack DeSantis
for
um for being too heavy-handed on one
hand but on the other hand they
supported every heavy-handed thing and
more so it's a difficult place to be and
and uh look I can understand an I guess
Theory radically an anti-desantis
anti-freedom position I can kind of
understand that
um I don't think it's right but it's it
makes a certain amount of sense what I
don't understand is the theory of
Charlie Chris candidacy
you know I I can understand someone
who's anti-desantist but pro-charley
Crist I just don't get it because the
guy is you know I mean the guy's an
empty suit as as John said he will say
whatever it takes
um just a shell of a human right and
again that's why I'm not bothering
showing clips and we know that obviously
we know the results of this election
here thank God we know them already it's
okay to say that like it's going to be
fine
um Carol I feel like I should just give
you an open-ended question or you know
basically tee it up to you you move down
here right around when I moved down here
you've got kids they're free they're
happy now it's it's been all good huh
it's so good
um yeah you know it was so funny when
Chris went after DeSantis for closing
schools because literally he's the
reason that schools are open not just in
Florida but I would say across the
country you know the point that I keep
coming back to is if there was no Ron
DeSantis I mean look other states also
opened but Ron DeSantis kind of took the
lead on it and if there was no Ron
DeSantis other states would remain
closed maybe till now we have no idea
what would have happened
um when DeSantis opens goals in
September of 2020 that was daring and
amazing and and really something but
then he also opened schools the
following year and they tried to stop
him then too I always talk about this
that the teachers unions the left they
wanted schools closed the media they
wanted schools closed fall 2021 so the
fact that he pushed back on it said I'm
opening schools again
um is a miracle really and he did an
amazing amazing job I couldn't be
happier to live here I feel so just
comforted by him being the governor
because I know nothing crazy is going to
happen he's not going to pass some weird
law about you know letting criminals out
or you know masking in schools I just
it's a comfort that I never had living
in a blue state that I have now
right and it's bizarrely something that
should just be obvious that everyone
should want and yet here we are uh John
this will give us a good segue into the
next segment when we get to New York but
uh you I feel like you're you're a
pretty solid Insider what do you think
the Florida Republicans can do to export
some of these ideas to maybe the states
that are about to get a red wave because
the Machinery here seems like it's
operating pretty well that's a great
question I just want to address one
thing before where you go I'm gonna play
devil's advocate here and say I am all
for the Charlie Chris side of that room
being locked down did you see with those
if I never have to be in the presence of
one of those filthy hippies again I
volunteer to lock them in from the
outside Button as many masks as they
didn't look very good I was trying to be
nice Dave you raise a great point so let
me let me walk away from crime for a
moment and look at what Florida is doing
led by Rhonda santis and our state CFO
our state Chief Financial Officer Jimmy
Petronas if you're a bank that Banks a
legitimate business because it has a
conservative bent
Firearms private Corrections outdooring
gear you can no longer do business with
the state of Florida in a state or
Municipal capacity you're going to lose
billions of dollars in business you
might lose tens of billions in pension
fund Investments those are the kinds of
policies that are very tangible that are
very effective that weaponize the it's
effectively and legally that Florida
Republicans should be exporting to other
states let's hit these massive
institutions that are totally woke with
esj and Dei let's hit them in the
billion dollar wallet I think that one
policy if I were uh if I were to ask the
question by the governor I haven't been
or or CFO Patronus I'd say let's get
behind that the banking policy and force
it on every state treasurer CFO or AG
whoever the respective uh Authority is
to the banks in that state and make sure
we start holding the financial
institutions the tasks yeah we've
covered it a little bit here but the
debanking thing and you know PayPal
putting penalties on people for
misinformation I mean that really is the
next Frontier of all this but let's
shift to some of the other States
because New York there is something
crazy happening in New York the place
that I was born that Carol fled from
Dave you lived in New York oh well John
of course you lived in New York Dave you
lived in New York at some point right
okay we've all lived we've all lived in
New York it was once a great state it
has become an absolute disaster New York
City is a freaking nightmare under Eric
Adams which is just an extension of de
Blasio hokel took over nobody's ever
voted for her she loves lockdowns she
would do it all again here is Lee zeldin
who just sort of appeared out of nowhere
in the last two months and he's leading
in some of the polls right now my
opponent still can't finish the sentence
you can't expect her to ever fix it but
New York leads the entire nation in
population lost because
she actually got asked this question by
the media a few weeks ago when she was
at Binghamton Airport she probably would
love to have a redo because she messed
it up that time for me you asked me why
does New York lead the entire nation
population loss because their wallets
their safety their freedom and their
quality of their kids education under
attack so they're hitting their breaking
point they're looking at other states
like the Carolinas Tennessee Texas
Florida and elsewhere and they feel like
their money will go further they'll feel
safer and they'll live life Freer the
state is at a Crossroads we're at a
Crossroads in 1994 when New York elected
George Pataki and we're at a crossroads
right now but as far as what happens
with Kathy Holcomb one party rule for
four more years outside's power of
self-described socialists we need
balance and Common Sense restored to
Albany
Carol I was super impressed by him I
watched the replay of the entire debate
it wasn't just that you know it's easy
to hit hocal because she's been so bad
it's like he's passionate he's honest he
also strikes me as a decent guy who
would pick up your pick your friends up
after school and take you to Burger King
or something like I think this is just
what New York needs I agree he's really
great even you know his primary
opponents like Rob astorino have been
openly supporting him and really pushing
him I think that's really a tell that
that they're kind of motivated to defeat
hokel and you know let bygones be
bygones
um yeah I think he's terrific and I
would love to see New York do the same
thing I know that a lot of people have
one foot out the door waiting to see
what's going to happen with this because
if it is hocal again if she gets you
know reelected and she can say look they
wanted me they wanted my policies they
wanted my ideas who knows what she's
going to do and you know winter is
coming coveted rates are going to spike
again because that's what covered rates
do in the winter in New York and she
could put the kids back in math she's
already suggested it she could easily
lock down schools she could do any
number of things that I think people
should be prepared for this is a really
important election for New York this is
a really make or break election for New
York and they should look at it like
that just to Echo what zeldin said there
they're giving me some numbers right now
so the population in New York in 2021
was about 19.8 million which was a 1.58
decline from the year before I mean
that's fairly significant uh John that
shouldn't surprise anybody right because
hokel even said we if you don't share
our values get going to Florida well
look at the four of us yeah yeah look I
mean they lost a congressional seat
Florida gained one but but I think Elias
I know Lee and Lee is is the guy you
just described real likable guy very
confident very well versed in the issues
crime is is off the charts and I can
speak to this one with authority I came
out of the police academy in 1993 under
David Dinkins right and crime was bad
but it wasn't this bad the criminals
weren't as bold yeah by the Numbers
there was more actual crime because the
years of losing uh bodies in the NYPD
due to fiscal problems and having a
rebuild and liberal policies but because
of the world culture the BLM arrives the
antifa arrives Dave what I'm seeing
right what I'm analyzing through the
lens experience and what I'm getting for
the men and women still on the job and
Carolina speaks to them as well you know
via the post the uh the boldness of the
criminal is much different even under
dink crime was bad the cops would roll
up we'd roll up in a more car they'd
still run now they spit at you they give
you the finger they make simulated uh
gestures like they're gonna shoot you
I've never seen boldness in criminals
like this because they were emboldened
starting in 2008 by the Obama
Administration and they still are by
Democrats running these cities and
that's what's super dangerous that's
what really puts the life of that single
mom on the bus stop going out her second
job in danger New Yorkers see that and
that directly relates to your wallet in
Commerce and that's why they're they're
leaving the state and mass
is that not only are the criminals
emboldened but under Dinkins there was
not a mass denial by the elites that
this was on you know I think like living
in Park Slope and seeing people in four
million dollar Brown Stones put defund
police signs in their windows that
wouldn't have happened in the den era
everybody understood that crime was high
and we should do something about it now
it's like what are you talking about
what crime is high no crime is
everything's fine you know isn't that a
little racist to say and I think that's
what makes it so impossible to fix
to give you a little more context on
that 1.58 it's about 320
000 people and most likely those are 320
000 people with jobs who are productive
members of society and good parts of
their community and everything else that
that's the crazy part of this uh Dave do
you think I think we've discussed this a
little bit and you write about this
fairly often like how bad do you think
it has to get in New York let's say he
does not win like what does New York
City end up looking like in a year from
now oh in a year from now
um or two years from now or ten years
from now I mean if they don't start the
turnaround now eventually it's going to
be a kind of Thunderdome situation
because
um I am look I mean I I it's very easy
to say that this kind of thing is
cyclical
um and that every time there's a an
action and a reaction and uh and and and
it goes kind of on and on forever well
that's fine but each time
um there is you know each time there's
there's kind of less grease on the wheel
so that it becomes harder and harder to
correct and and the correction is never
um you know it's it's never really
complete so you know I mean what I
always think is that
could a Rudy Giuliani show up next year
or in five years or in 10 years and and
just fix New York well there could be a
Rudy Giuliani on the uh on the horizon
to do that but I think the voters who
would would elect someone like that
um are Vanishing a lot of those people
uh who elected Rudy for example and and
Bloomberg you know they're here in
Florida
um were there or they're elsewhere they
they took advantage of of uh of high uh
High rents and property prices and they
said you know what we're out and um you
know so so what you have is you've got
an erosion of the middle class in in um
in the same way that you've got really
in San Francisco and just look to San
Francisco to see what what what the deal
is you know every once in a while it
gets to be even too much for for the the
crazy people of San Francisco who have
completely uh uh gotten rid of their
middle class look just just this morning
I saw right before we started that
somebody broke into Nancy Pelosi's house
and assaulted her husband I mean it's
it's literally coming to Nancy's door
also to your point you know Giuliani
didn't appear out of nowhere I think he
was attorney general he was going after
the mafia for 20 years meaning that
there were people in the system that
were being trained to succeed in New
York John is there anyone even left in
New York that that could be the that
type of person yeah yeah so Rudy was the
U.S attorney for the southern district
of New York and like you said he was the
guy who busted up the mob he was
synonymous with being the guy whose
office took out John Gotti so he was
already a larger than life character
he lost the first time he ran into
Dinkins then it was a landslide and
Carol I'm so glad you brought that up I
people forget that so he ran at 89 laws
people were like man buyers or Morris
but he was a larger than life guy he he
was like a local Hometown hero national
hero Dave's right the people that voted
for Rudy are gone you know you know Dave
Rubin you grew up in Long Island right
carols from the city when I drove
through Queens where I grew up during
the Giuliani Administration it still
looked like Queens I drove through
Queens about a year and a half two years
ago and it looked like Sanaa Yemen there
were the signs in Arabic no signs in
English so Dave's 100 right people that
would vote for the next Rudy are gone
the population has declined I don't see
the city coming back I think New York
City could very well look like Baltimore
sooner rather than later because there
really is nobody on the bench Dave and
not to get too into the weeds when Rudy
was elected we also had a Republican
party infrastructure in New York state
it's a miracle to me how well zeldon is
doing because when George Pataki left he
took that infrastructure with him a
bunch of billionaires his buddies they
were all older guys they left and it
fell in on itself it never really
properly rebuilt for Grassroots efforts
door knocking Etc so there's a lot of
reasons why infrastructure reasons or
even get to the candidate why it's going
to be difficult if not impossible for a
Giuliani uh bloomberg-like guy on crime
anyway to win again as a New York city
mayor yeah it's interesting I mean look
hopefully zeldin starts the process and
then either maybe a couple people come
back or some some people that are there
get braver or something like that but
the fact that New York is just on the
table and being discussed right now is
amazing another state that there's some
interesting stuff happening is Michigan
and Gretchen Whitmer was was maybe the
worst when you know could I compare
anyone to Newsom I'm not sure but I mean
she was not only locking kids out of
school and for forced uh vaccines and
everything else she literally was
telling people not to do gardening in
their yards during covid I don't know if
you guys know this but I actually there
was a day I went to Home Depot we did it
on video and I bought a whole bunch of
seeds and I just sent them to people in
Michigan just so that they could plant
tomatoes uh here's Tudor Dixon who's the
Republican who I didn't know much about
until the last two weeks going after
Whitmer for Fallon on covet the governor
is being dishonest once again but that's
what you do when you don't have policies
to run on when you killed more seniors
than almost any other state when you
were told to stop the policy but you
kept it going when you could had such
extreme unemployment fraud that you lost
eight and a half billion dollars worth
of taxpayer money
she crushed our economy 3 000 businesses
in three thousand restaurants died under
Gretchen Whitmer and never came back
Carol before we get to the issue on this
one well what's the deal with shoulder
pads uh you know I like the Golden Girls
but those shoulder pads Lady it's like I
hear you I like what you're laying out
there but a little too angular for me
right it sends a message of who's in
charge I just don't think that we need
to have that message all the time you
know putting that aside though what she
was saying yeah no I like it's just it's
crazy to me that Whitmer straight up
lied that she only closed schools for
three months and that the media
obviously lets her get away with it I
would love to see Michigan I would love
to see her lose uh Whitmore has just
been a disaster the whole time and I
think it was just the trifecta of her
Andrew Cuomo and Gavin Newsom that
really kind of almost bullied the other
states to follow it was it was it was
like this is the Democrat position where
the a team and this is what we're going
to be doing and I think she's been so
wrong for so long I would love to see
Michigan toss her yeah Dave are you
amazed that they can do it like the
lying never seems to surprise me at this
point but for her to get up there
Whitmer and say this three-month thing
which they were literally in lockdowns
even into this year certain schools in
Michigan so it's an it's a bold face lie
nobody you know nobody called her out on
it except the other candidate meaning
the moderators didn't but it never
stopped right it just doesn't stop and
we have to kind of accept that
yeah I agree it's uh it's it's it's
completely insane I mean she's she's
been one of the as he correctly pointed
out she's been one of the more
contemptible of the uh of the blue State
Governors
um you know say what you will about
about uh about New York and uh and
California
um I mean those are those are kind of
you know two big Coastal states with uh
with with huge population centers I mean
um Michigan should be a
kind of relatively level-headed Place uh
but um
but it's just been terrible and then you
and then you add to it the um the weird
kidnapping you know so-called kidnapped
bed napping plot yeah that was kind of
at the at the at the center of this
um which which Julie Kelly has been uh
really remarkably dogged
um and and has has been on this um
a bit on this story from day one I mean
just the the kind of weirdness of the
federal uh of the FBI involvement in in
that one yeah I mean I think she's one
of those these people who's got no
redeeming qualities and I would love to
see Tudor Dixon
um uh defeat Whitmer
John what do we do with the people who
did all of this to us what do we do you
know when Whitmer gets taken out
whatever whenever it is whether she
loses this election or she gets another
term but these people that did all this
and lied about it do we just let them
off scot-free and just go on or or do
does there need to be some kind of
Retribution oh we need to crush him so
full disclosure Tudor Dixon is a very
close personal friend of mine for many
years I was actually uh one of the
people who helped her select her
campaign team for this and I only say
that I only say that yeah and she was
about to hire the wrong people and I
said call this person and it's worked
out as you see I just I know tutor well
and I knew who she'd mesh with I also
knew she was real and the reason I knew
she was real is about two years ago two
and a half years ago she called me we
speak pretty regularly she said hey I've
got this crazy idea you're gonna think
I'm nuts I said watch said I want to run
for governor in Michigan whitmer's
destroying my kids lives she's
destroying my family's business she grew
up in a steel foundry business her dad
recently passed wonderful guy of cancer
he built this very successful company
she said I'm watching everything my
family work for everything my family
built everything our friends and our
families built being destroyed by this
woman I want to run I said I don't think
it's crazy at all this is exactly why
people should run so everything tutor's
saying and and I I gave you the full
disclosure I'm not saying this because
she's a friend of mine and I adore her I
want to see her win everything she's
saying is from the heart because she did
her family lived that they suffered
financially economically from a business
perspective because of that we need to
crush these people we need to crush
these people vouchers should be under
criminal investigation Whitmer should be
under criminal investigation every
Democrat who took your money locked you
down ruined your child's education
they should be the ones being perp
walked out of their homes at gunpoint
being crushed financially by the
criminal legal bills this cannot go
unchecked this cannot go unanswered yeah
it's funny because I'm usually not a
retribution guy but at some level it's
like if we don't they will do it again
we just know Carol as you said earlier
it's like if if uh hokel wins it's like
the signal to her is hey let's roll
let's do it again on top of all of her
Shady business dealings and who they
were given government contracts out to
and everything else so let's move over
to the to the other debate that
obviously was the big one sort of on
social media and everything is
Pennsylvania Dr Oz everyone knows
basically what you're getting with Dr Oz
he's I think probably a former liberal
who's like a waking up conservative
strikes me as a decent enough guy like
you can't say he's some crazy far-right
maniac and then you've got John Federman
who yes he had a stroke six months ago
but the guy is really having trouble
speaking or communicating in any way
whatsoever the debate was an absolute
disaster here's Oz taking it to
fetterman on crime I'm running for the
U.S Senate because Washington keeps
getting it wrong with extreme positions
I want to bring civility balance all the
things that you want to see because
you've been telling it to me on the
campaign Trail and by doing that we can
bring us together in a way that has not
been done of late Democrats Republicans
talking to each other John fetterman
takes everything to an extreme and those
extreme positions hurt us all let's take
crime as an example because it's been
such a big problem
Maureen Faulkner accompanied me today to
the studio you know that her husband was
a police officer in Philadelphia he was
brutally murdered John Federman during
this crime wave has been trying to get
as many murderers convicted and
sentenced to life in prison out of jail
as possible including people who are
similar to the man who murdered her
husband he does it without the the rest
of the parole board agreeing he's doing
it without the families on board these
radical positions extend beyond crime to
wanting to legalize all drugs to open
the border to raising our taxes I want
Washington to be civil again well you
need it to be less radical John Federman
unfortunately would bring that
I'm curious what you guys think of my
diagnosis of Dr Oz I think he's really
going to grow into this and be an
excellent politician it seems to me that
he's been mugged by reality which is
what happens to all liberals and now
he's he's learning on the Fly I don't
know that he would have been this
forward on some of these things Dave
what do you think about that
um look I mean I I don't know I kind of
remain skeptical of Oz
uh for uh you know a number of reasons
there's that there is the uh the the the
turkey AKP thing which is kind of weird
um the fact that he is he is literally a
dual citizen is uh isn't
um you know of the US and turkey is I'm
not thrilled about that that said I
agree he's really coming into his own
um in the last uh in the last really in
the last month or a couple of weeks
especially as a contrast with fetterman
because fetterman is I mean it's it's
undeniable at this point that the guy
has has
um you know if he was coherent and uh
and together ever
um he is not so right now and uh and
that debate really kind of showed it and
it's and uh and you see it with with the
folks who are um who are kind of
regretting their vote I think there's
you know a popular Google search in in
Pennsylvania is how can I get my early
vote back
uh because they people saw the debate
and they said oh my God I cannot vote
for this guy this guy is is just is just
not mentally well and by the way there
was a massive Push by the Democrats to
get the early vote out knowing that they
could do it before the debate because
this is exactly what they expected Carol
as a as a media creature what do you
think the reaction should have been to
fetterman because obviously everybody
was clipping the stuff and okay he can't
speak fine but then there were an awful
lot of people running cover for him what
would what would have been a fair
assessment of his performance so funny
because I know that the liberal media is
obviously covering for him and helping
the Democrats and all that but they have
done so much harm to Democrats in
Pennsylvania if you think about it they
must have known before the primary what
bad shape he was in the stroke happened
for the primary Democrats could have
gone with Conor lamb in Pennsylvania but
there was a massive cover-up of how bad
that stroke was and if that's how he is
right now imagine how he was in the few
days following the stroke so people knew
and didn't do anything about it if I
were a democrat in Pennsylvania I'd be
really pissed off right now that you
left me with this candidate who is
clearly not up for the job and I could
have had somebody else I agree with you
though that I think Oz is growing into
the the kind of the ideology but I do
think you know ultimately he is still a
moderate but look that's Pennsylvania
what are you gonna do fetterman is far
far left I've followed this guy's career
for a long time because first time I saw
him on TV I was like this is a danger
he's extremely far left and at the time
he was very plain spoken and I thought
he could really appeal to a lot of
people
um so I I think that anybody but
fetterman is good for Pennsylvania and
Oz is better than I expected John it
seems like Philly has a lot of the same
problems that New York City has right I
mean every day on Twitter you can see
these crazy videos block after block
drugs complete you know crime and
homelessness I mean stuff that that
literally looks like third world country
stuff is happening on the streets of
Philly right now and yet people seem to
think fetterman might be okay even
though he wants to release more
criminals by you know two things that
real quick answer to your question I
agree with Yana is evolving right now I
put him on the Romney Rubio scale with
Romney being on the left Rubio on the
right he's about 70 some odd percent
toward Rubio that's how I see Oz right
now but things can change hopefully
he'll prove me wrong and be somewhere
between Rubio and Mike Lee but uh you
know that said look Philly you can point
to one problem in the city of
Philadelphia two words one guy Larry
krasner the D.A he was George soros's
first experiment with backing a far left
radical D.A that didn't want to
prosecute crime I believe Republicans in
Pennsylvania and the legislature though
and not that it's really going to go
anywhere but Republicans uh yesterday
day before introduced articles of
impeachment for Larry krasner finally
the Philadelphia district attorney and
it's very simple Dave if a district
attorney refuses to prosecute violent
crimes the police can't justify overtime
in arresting violent criminals it
becomes pointless right because what
happens is the far left city council
goes and they and they stack the deck
and they'll say to the police wow you
spent all these millions in overtime and
you got no convictions you guys really
screwed up the DA's office will say well
they didn't bring those good enough
cases knowing full well that's a lie
knowing full well that the cops couldn't
bring cases because they wouldn't
prosecute them you know who suffers you
know suffers we don't suffer
wealthy whites on the main line don't
suffer inner city blacks and Hispanics
suffer from these leftist policies I
worked in a 99 non-white command in the
NYPD my perps were people of color but
my Victim were people of color that's
who's suffering you've got four to six
percent of the neighborhood that's the
criminal element you know 94 to 96 that
are the Working Poor the working lower
middle class that's who the Democrats
are torturing with these policies so
Philadelphia needs to wake up and vote
itself out of this problem by getting
rid of people like krasner the mayor Jim
Kenny they've got these radical leftists
doing this to them but they keep voting
for them so until they stop doing that
it's not going to change yeah and by the
way I don't know if you saw it but
krasner gave a press conference I think
it was about a week ago and basically
said if you criticize us on our crime
it's because you're racist which is what
they do in every Big City non-stop it's
just crazy I got one more thing for you
guys Real Clear Politics has put up
their predictions and they're usually
ballpark pretty good and this is I mean
this is super interesting they're now
saying that uh about a week and a half
from today the Senate is basically going
to be 53 Republicans 47 Democrats so of
course the the interesting ones there
they have Oz winning Pennsylvania they
have Adam lack salt uh flipping Nevada
which would be interesting Blake Masters
flipping Arizona Herschel Walker
flipping Georgia they've got Rubio
winning here in Florida Ron Johnson
Wisconsin JD Vance in Ohio so that's
that seems strikes me as pretty bullish
but it doesn't seem that impossible Dave
what do you think
I don't think it seems that impossible
at all
um how did it um what did it have for
Masters I'm sorry I couldn't yeah it had
it had Blake winning yeah fantastic yeah
I mean look I this is the direction it's
heading in uh every single day you see
worse news for Democrats and and not
just in Florida where Democrats are
getting completely blown out but uh but
in other places as well and it really
makes sense aside from the kind of
structural advantages that Republicans
have of you know this it's an off-year
election where the uh where the party
out of power always always always gains
some
um it's a particularly rough environment
for Democrats so um and and they really
have nothing and you can see I mean the
the evidence of all of this is that the
only thing they want to talk about is
abortion which is the thing that will
motivate their most fanatical uh single
white
um uh female voters well uh Dave I got
to tell you they're also it's not just
abortion because they're also bringing
covid back right Biden just in the last
two days it's another emergency even
though he said it was over shot right
right and uh we got that and of course
suddenly uh Carol they're talking about
election fraud now we're allowed to talk
about it because they think it's not
going to go well into aux Hillary put
out this crazy video about the
right-wing conspiracy coming for the
election uh you can MSNBC almost every
day it's all about voter suppression
even though in Georgia they're having
record number of people voting so you
can see what they're doing right
so the record number in Georgia is
obviously only proving that there's more
suppression Dave obviously you know
what's really interesting to me about
this election is that I think often um
going into an election you know
especially when things are close uh
Democrats have this like we're gonna win
everything kind of attitude whereas
Republicans always have a we're going to
lose everything attitude and like you'll
have like you know a completely red seat
in Texas and they'll send me emails like
Nancy Pelosi is coming from my seat and
like that's always the Republican like
kind of stance like we're gonna lose
everything's gonna be terrible and now
for like the first time I see this like
you know hope on the Republican side
which I hope is not misplaced I actually
am fully I think uh the RCP guess is
where I am or prediction is where I am
um I think that all of those are
probably going to end up uh there I I my
only kind of exception to that maybe is
that I think Herschel Walker is going to
get into a runoff I don't know that he
wins it outright on Tuesday that's my
only change from that yeah John are you
as bullish as this map
yeah I really am because remember it's
the RCP the real clear politics average
right so the average in a bunch of polls
many of which are about a plus six demo
oversample so I think the fact that it
shows Republicans up by three means
mathematically any way that we could
possibly do better do better and I'm in
agreement with Carol a Herschel Walker's
the only one right now who concerns me
but but again it's an average of poll so
I think we're in really good shape
and by the way for the record yesterday
they caught that hot mic moment with
Chuck Schumer talking to Joe Biden and
he said that Georgia was the one that
they can't believe that's slipping away
so yeah we might we might just be there
well my Florida friends it was nice to
see you as always what's that next time
we see each other democracy will have
been completely destroyed
we can only hope our democracy all right
it was great seeing you guys uh we will
do this over drinks in the not too
distant future I'm sure and I'm just
going to finish up for a couple of
minutes but have a good weekend guys
thanks
bye-bye
all right everybody we we are almost
there right don't lose your nerve at
this point and don't get too
overconfident even here in Florida like
okay fine DeSantis is going to win we
understand that but it's like let's get
this win to 12 points 14 points
something bananas with the idea in mind
that he only won by 30 000 votes last
time like all the trends should go in
the right way and it's not so that we
can then stifle dissent and censor
people and all of those things it's so
that we can just restore an America that
as I keep saying we we've gotten so
close right to the precipice right to
the end of the road right to the ledge
The Edge where we were about to go off
the cliff and then maybe because of this
midterm election enough of us turn away
from it and Florida continues to lead
the country to a to a place of freedom
but New York turns away and Michigan
turns away Cali ain't gonna turn away
right now actually there was another
gubernatorial debate it was Gavin
Newsome versus whoever the Republican is
I'm not I'm not even sure but nothing
about it was talked about or viral or
anything because California has made its
decision but there is a way to turn most
of America around and I think it's
happening right now let's get to a
couple locals comments and then uh guess
what we're having for lunch today guys I
didn't tell you
Chick-fil-A
Daphne she made it happen she made it
happen she looked at me and I knew she
had that thing in her eye which just
said Chick-fil-A Amy Says major red
winds in Florida up and down the ballot
yeah Florida
I think across the board Rubio obviously
is gonna is gonna win his seat DeSantis
is going to crush it by the way I will
be broadcasting live from on Election
night from uh DeSantis Campaign
Headquarters so hopefully we'll get the
governor and a couple other people we'll
have a couple uh surprises in store I
can't say anything else about that at
the moment but but yeah there's good
things happening in Florida you guys you
guys get that uh Cindy says we take the
house by a lot but lose the Senate sorry
to say that's that's interesting because
I would wonder uh we'll look in the
comments but I wonder what you're
thinking Cindy on this because okay so I
could see as Carol said George is going
to be kind of close like Warnock might
pull it out do you think that Blake is
going to lose in Arizona like which are
the ones because 53-47 that seems just
about right but we all live in our own
little Bubbles and maybe we're missing
something and and the Blake one Masters
is in a very tough race in Arizona so so
we shall see and and look even
Pennsylvania by any sane estimation Oz
should win
but anything is possible and because of
that early voting that people all these
people the Democrats pushed people to
vote before the debate because they knew
how bad it was going to be Tony says
Republicans take the house and the
Senate DeSantis by 10 at least and many
leftist tears Yeah by 10 at least
wouldn't that be a beautiful thing uh
guys as always uh subscribe if you have
not on YouTube and Rumble uh this was I
think our biggest week ever across
platforms and it's or we're in the midst
of our biggest month things are good
here I'm glad that you guys are watching
and sharing and paying attention and
that the things that we're doing are
relevant and we're going to save this
country
now let's eat some Chick-fil-A all right
see you on Monday